all right so
this is what little nausea put out i
don't understand what it is exactly okay
fill in the old man here so little
nasdaq the out and loud proud
sure probably loves them yeah so he's a
out and proud gay african-american uh
rapper huge huge super talented super
talented yeah so this uh boozy badass
he's an older like og like street comic
i'm sorry rapper doesn't
doesn't play comes from a different kind
of cloth does not play yeah but uh he
always like talks [ __ ] to little nods
about being gay so a little nas which i
think is funny he's like oh i got a new
track coming out with boozy badass y'all
get ready and likey because he knows
boozy can't stand them
now you see boozy's [ __ ] remarked
you're like oh yeah you're gonna work
anywhere dude he went super hard
terribly hard oh dude yeah he made a
video
no he hit a tweet but first i'll play a
little nausea because this is like
tongue-in-cheek it's not like
what would that dog be so i've been
working on this song with a little
boosie bro
i had this song a little boosy for me to
come out
[ __ ] firing family laughter
sound little booty to come out
she's just being silly because that guy
hates him
okay so i don't know what this is oh no
he's in control right now okay
and then boozy was like excuse me this
is what he wrote i'm not gonna read it i
know but you can tell what he's saying
here stop trolling me the f word lol a
whole you know [ __ ] playing with a
gangsta keeps shaking my head dick and
getting
[ __ ] in your ass
and peace and actually hit yourself
yourself i would too if i was you uh if
you has to commit suicide that's also
what this world is in favor okay nobody
wants you here
it's so and it's on his official twitter
like that's
you could also
ignore somebody these people who just
have to respond this way yeah it's just
unbelievable that's pretty that's
aggressive that's hardcore how old is
this he's older like maybe in his 40s
old enough to know better then oh yeah
this is why instagram keeps taking down
yeah instagram keeps taking his account
down and everything he's 38. he's pretty
good oh i thought he's not he's not
young that's old enough to know better
i'm saying like he's young enough to
understand this generation to not say
stupid [ __ ] he's kind of a gangster he's
got money yeah yeah
i don't know about money but i know he's
i know he's you know
he's he's pretty gangster shouldn't be
doing that though no that's just that's
[ __ ] hateful yeah no
yeah that's aggressive why say his
little booze he had billionaire well
that's just someone asking yeah
i'll answer that for you yeah
but you know elon musk yesterday made
thirty thirty seven billion dollars it's
the most anybody has ever made in one
day i think that's [ __ ] i
anyway this is booty boozy badass's
response after all the backlash
if y'all think
if anyone because there's audio
listeners too
for real for real
the realest yeah my buddy was in uh
philly and he told me that all this
politically correct stuff did not get to
the hood in philly he goes all his
friends are just using like all kind of
the f word and he's like whoa whoa he's
like man i've been in l.a a long time
yeah hollywood's a different animal yeah
holly was a different animal but